Continuing
in the story of
in rebuilding the Kaa as recounted by
Abdullahb Abbas on his authority that
the messenger of Allah
wasallam tells us of this story of the
rebuilding of the Kaa. the most major
rebuilding of the Kaa and this lasted
all the way until our prophet
sallall.aii wasallam's lifetime. He was
a young man in his late 20s when the
caba was again rebuilt due to you know
genuual general wear and tear as what
happens and you know the kappa is
located in a valley and so rain and
flooding and these things they all have
an erosive effect on physical objects.
And so when Ibraimisam
arrived back for the third time to visit
is he had already received the command
of Allah to return to is and to rebuild
the Kaa there with the aid of his son is
who's now a man twice married.
He says,
meaning the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam,
[Arabic recitation]
[Silence]
And so when Ibraim returned,
he found his son
is
this time with his back on a tree on a
major dha. Is it the same tree
that he left is under with his mother
when he was just an infant
perhaps.
But here we have the well of Zam
and he returns.
Things have come full circle. is now a
young man. And he is sitting
under this Dha, the same tree that
Ibraim, the same kind of tree that
Ibraim had left him under with his back
to it. And he was sharpening
his arrows under this tree. And so when
is saw him, he stood up and he welcomed
his father. And they you know embraced
as fathers and sons do. The prophet says
and then after this Ibraimisam
said my son Allah has commanded me with
a commandment
and I
have come here to fulfill this command.
Before is even hears the command, he
says, "Do my father what Allah has
commanded you." He said, "And you will
help me. You will aid me." He said, "And
I will aid you. I will be your aid in
fulfilling this commandment." Now,
they've already had this conversation
before, haven't they? When isam
was a young boy under the age of
puberty, probably no more than eight or
nine years old, Ibraimis
propositioned him with the commandment
of Allah. And is responded in the same.
And so now 10 years or so have gone by.
And the same question, the same wording
that is found in
we see here the prophet uses in this
narration sai
he said I will help you. Yes. And so
Ibraim said you see this mound here.
Have you ever seen a a pitcher's mound
in a baseball field? You see how it's a
mound? It's very lightly above the
surrounding ground. This is where the
Cabba was built was to be built and the
foundations were under that mound.
Because the Cabba isn't just
foundations, there's also a treasure
underneath the Cabba. it's not been
seen in thousands of years, but there is
a treasure underneath the Cabba. There
are things underneath the Kaa that Allah
only knows about
in the restoration of the Kaa that took
place in the time of Jahya
before our prophet was a messenger while
he was a young man in his late 20s early
30s. They started to dig and dig and dig
to strengthen and deepen the foundations
of the cabba because they had demolished
it entirely to rebuild it. So they
started to dig and dig and dig and they
digged until they reached a place where
there was nothing but light coming out
of the foundations
and they were unable to dig any deeper
and penetrate it. and they became a
little bit scared
and they backed off and they started the
foundations there. So there is a a kind
of mound there. And so he says, "Do you
see this this mound here? This echa
I have been commanded to build the house
of Allah here on this mound or to
rebuild the house of Allah here on this
mount." And so is and Ibraim Ibraim
primary is secondary and helping began
to rebuild the Kaa and they rebuilt and
rebuilt and rebuilt until it was too
tall even for Ibraim. And so is then
brought him a stone
that is in the shape of a block for him
to stand on
to complete the raising of the
structure. And that is what we have
today. Allah made Ibraim's
feet to sink slightly into that stone.
And the footprints of Ibraim, this is
what is referred to as Ibraim. that
Allah mentions in surah Bakar that's the
stone that is brought him that his
father stood on to raise the building
and his feet
you know they were made to sink just
slightly into into the this stone and
when you go to visit the Cabba today
you can see M Ibraim it's there it's in
a kind of behind glass people can't
really touch it. , it used to be
exposed, but it's no longer exposed.
Behind glass, you can see it. And it's
the sunnah to make from behind Ibraim.
And it has there that remnants of
Ibraim. And as they raised
the structure and raised the walls, they
were building it. And Ibraim was placing
the stones and is
handing him the stones and they are
making dua as Allah mentioned in Bakar
with each stone and with each portion
of the
our Lord except from us.
Indeed, certainly you are the
all-heering, the all knowing. And so we
will leave off with that inshallah.
We'll continue this tomorrow night.
[Arabic recitation]